Batman historian,
we'll brooker one set the defining
characteristic of Gotham city must be
there was always correct
night and day.
He has only increased police forces,
helpless to cope with the situation,
but they have an ally.
Man.
There has to be crime in Gotham because
Batman is on one key level,
the one who fights crime.
This highlights the inseparable
connection between Batman and his city.
It's actually more like a circular
connection and that one is always
creating and perpetuating the other.
It was Gotham city that killed Bruce
Wayne's parents in the form of a petty
thief that it's corrupt.
Conditions created sending in motion a
chain of events that led to the Batman's
obsessive mission to rid them of crime
and obsession that fostered a darker and
more twisted criminality.
I'm an agent of chaos.
In the beginning,
Gotham was just a backdrop,
a setting,
and deep.
It wasn't even Gotham.
It was New York City until detective
comics number 48 in the 1943 and 49
television serial's of Batman.
Most of the action,
largely due to budgets takes place in
interiors on sound stages.
Little attempt is made to signify Gotham
as a whole.
The same is true for the Adam West
Batman series in the 19 sixties when the
character was at the height of camp
scrub through the entire feature length
movie from 1966 and you won't see so
much as a skyscraper.
When the Adam West show failed,
Batman writers brought a darker tone to
the stories.
They brought an extended continuity and
continuity meant that individual
locations in Gotham gained importance
and the city itself started to breathe
as a character.
This run of dark comics culminated in
1986 with Frank Miller's dark knight
returns,
which plumbed the obsessive tortured
psyche of the Batman and found a
counterpoint to that troubled mind in
the diseased crime ridden streets of
Gotham.
That essential feeling was intensified
even more and three years later,
Gotham city became a nightmare in what
has become the most iconic imagining of
the caped crusaders home.
Tim Burton and Anton first fashioned to
city as if hell burst through the
pavement and grew drawing from a number
of garishly juxtaposed architectural
styles and the charcoal drawings of Hugh
Ferris.
The creators of 1990 nines,
Batman took the eighties fears of
worsening crime and augmented them to a
kafkaesque love.
That aesthetic was made more grand and
in Burton's sequel Batman returns,
and three years later,
a batman forever depicted at Gotham that
was flashier,
colorful,
somehow even more removed from reality.
Finally,
what was mccobb and genuinely inspired
in Burton's imagination became Gadi and
genuinely ridiculous in 1997 fourth
installment in the series Batman and
Robin as monkey business,
and yet as the movie's soured,
Burton's vision of Gotham television and
comics,
we're taking all the best parts of the
1989 aesthetic and developing a deeper
identity for the city and the Stellar
Batman,
the animated series.
Gotham city is all dark deco,
as if the 19 thirties world's fair had
gone on for another 60 years in the
comics,
Batman was more low than ever to leave.
Gotham and Gotham itself became more
isolated and separated from the rest of
the world.
And the famous art called no man's land.
The national government chooses to
abandoned Gotham entirely after the city
is almost destroyed by an earthquake.
The island quickly carved up by gangs
and villains becomes a hell on earth.
Christopher Nolan made a similar
isolating move in Batman begins when the
police raised the bridges to stop escape
criminals from fleeing the city and
again in the dark,
knight rises,
when Bain destroys those bridges.
Of course Nolan's Gotham is decidedly
more grounded and realistic than its
predecessors,
especially in the Dark Knight Burton's
Gotham may be more nightmarish,
but a Gotham that resembles our own
world can be even more terrifying when
it's shown to be fragile in the face of
a violent disregard for the established
order from its earliest onscreen
depictions in the 19 forties to the
latest in a series of gruesome video
games and a network tv show that bears
its name.
Gotham has been flexible to account for
a changing world and a changing Batman.
The one constant is crying and
irrepressible criminal underclass that
plagues the streets with whom the police
are either in league or powerless to
stop.
Indeed,
the Batman is by definition unable to
stop this scourge to or else his
existence would be unjustified.
You defending a city,
so corrupt,
we have infiltrated every level of its
infrastructure.
Gotham,
I think is totally unique in the history
of cities real or imagined existing for
more than 70 years.
We have an exhaustive knowledge of it's
attitude of its field of places.
They're like Wayne Tower or Arkham
asylum on crime,
Allie,
yet unlike a real city,
we can't map it out in the traditional
sense and every attempt to do so is
subject to change in sort of absurd.
Gotham is a city that's performed.
We know it by the stories that happened
there by the spaces generated from
encounters in the night.
In this view,
it's many versions.
Don't register as inconsistencies would
cohere into perhaps a new way to think
of cities as a site of constant
reinvention and varied interpretation as
an expression of the traumas that are
reenacted by those who have suffered and
as a place that can't be mapped by its
buildings and streets,
but by the events and people and minds
that make them
everybody,
and thanks for watching.
If you think this is the kind of content
that you're not seeing anywhere else on
youtube or the Internet,
you can pledge to my channel by clicking
right here,
going to my Patrion,
giving as little as a dollar per video.
This is a full time job made possible by
you guys,
you know,
these take like 40 or 50 hours to make.
I work like nine or 10 hours a day doing
these and I'm having so much fun and I
think the quality of the content has
gotten better since I've gone full time
and there's still a lot more stuff I
want to experiment with and do.
And that's all made possible by you.
Um,
so thanks again.
There are still some stickers left.
Nerdwriter stickers.
$3 a video you can pledge there.
Get them there.
Um,
yeah.
Thanks a lot.
This Batman video is so much fun to me.